Il y a 40 000 ans,  durant l'âge de pierre, toute l'Europe était habitée par les Hommes de Néandertal.
De fiers chasseurs.
À l'exception d'eux-mêmes, ils n'ont jamais vu d'êtres humains.
Soudain,  des intrus apparaissent sur leur terrain de chasse.
Ils ont l'air différent, et sont différents.
Des Hommes modernes.
Le début de la fin des Néandertaliens.
Que s'est-il passé entre ces hommes de l'âge de pierre, et nos ancêtres ?
Se sont-ils battus ?
Ou mélangés ?
Se seraient-ils même reproduits entre eux ?
Quelle est la part de Néandertal en nous ?
Peu m'importe de savoir qui a couché avec qui, il y a 30 ou 40 000 ans.
Ils peuvent faire ce qu'ils veulent.
Je m'intéresse à ce qui me concerne, aujourd'hui.
Les Néandertaliens, un mythe dans le monde entier.
Ils étaient forts.
Ils ont survécu dans un environnement hostile.
Nos plus proches parents,  nos frères de l'ère glaciaire.
Leur vie, comme leur mort, ont troublé les chercheurs.
Les Néandertaliens ont survécu 300 000 ans dans l'Europe de l'ère glaciaire :  nous n'avons même pas existé aussi longtemps.
La question est : "Pourquoi ont-ils disparu ?"
Les Néandertaliens sont les seuls autres humains avec lesquels nous avons partagé cette planète, pendant quelques milliers d'années.
Apprendre à mieux les connaître,  c'est aussi apprendre à nous connaître nous-mêmes.
Voici une questions que je me pose depuis très longtemps :
Comment l'Homme moderne a-t-il pu se propager,  et devenir, d'une manière ou d'une autre, la forme dominante de la biologie humaine, dans un laps de temps géologiquement assez court,  sur une période de 10 ou 20 000 ans ?
L'énigme du code génétique de Néandertal.
Une équipe scientifique internationale est en train de percer ce mystère.
À Leipzig, en Allemagne,  des chercheurs de l'Institut Max Planck d'anthropologie évolutionniste, sont les premiers à avoir décodé le génome d'un être humain disparu.
Pour le généticien suédois Svante Päbo, c'est le rêve de toute une vie qui se réalise.
En fait, nous avons commencé à travailler sur Néandertal avant 97.
Il y a cinq ans, le décodage du génome complet était encore un rêve.
Ça fait trois ans que nous y travaillons vraiment.
Depuis un an, nous avons les données et nous les évaluons.
Nous sommes prêts, maintenant.
Nous pouvons oser en parler.
Johannes Krause, chercheur passionné, est impliqué depuis le début.
Jusqu'ici, c'est le décodage qui a posé le plus de problème à l'équipe.
Nous devions constamment trouver de nouvelles méthodes, de nouvelles technologies.
Nous avons dû employer différentes méthodes et ce n'était pas toujours facile.
C'était beaucoup d'excitation, de tension aussi, car les attentes étaient très hautes.
La grande question est : avons-nous gardé quelque chose de Néandertal ?
Le musée régional rhénan, à Bonn.
Cette valise contient les os les plus célèbres au monde.
Ce sont les joyaux de l'archéologie allemande.
Ralph Schmitz est le gardien de ce trésor.
Le premier Néandertalien retrouvé, dont le nom a été donné à toute une espèce d'humains.
L'archéologue Ralph Schmitz connaît ces os mieux que quiconque.
Toute sa vie professionnelle est centrée dessus.
Néandertal.
Cet homme préhistorique, qui a vécu il y a 42 000 ans, est mort, à l'âge de 40 ans environ.
Tous ces milliers d'années n'ont laissé de lui que 16 os.
Contiennent-ils une clé,  celle qui révèlera le secret du génome de Néandertal ?
Il est le plus célèbre des Allemands, mais surtout, un Européen.
C'est la seule espèce humaine à s'être développée en Europe.
Et s'il y a une espèce d'humain qui représente l'Europe et les Européens, c'est bien l'homme de Néandertal.
Cette histoire commence en 1856, dans une carrière près de Düsseldorf, en Allemagne.
C'est une dure journée pour les travailleurs.
Forant la pierre, creusant sous la chaleur torride, ils tombent sur des ossements  qu'ils jettent sans réfléchir au bas du talus.
Le monde n'aurait jamais entendu parler de Néandertal, si le propriétaire de la carrière n'avait pas été curieux.
S'agit-il des restes d'un ours des cavernes ?
Passionné des fossiles, le propriétaire ordonne aux ouvriers de chercher d'autres ossements.
Ils trouvent un crâne,  comme personne n'en avait encore jamais vu.
Étrange, qu'est-ce que cela signifie ?
Ces os sont apparus à Neandertal, un coin romantique sur la rivière Düssel, près de Mettmann.
Jusqu'au milieu du 19e siècle, la vallée de Neander  était un site naturel intact et splendide.
Des falaises de craie escarpées de 50 mètres de haut bordaient la Düssel.
Cette gorge étroite et romantique s'appelait Gesteins.
Elle fut ensuite rebaptisée Neanderthal en l'honneur du poète Joachim  Neander.
La vallée de Neander lorsqu'elle était encore intacte, il y a deux cents ans.
Le Néandertalien, a sûrement été enterré par sa tribu,  dans l'une de ces grottes.
Des hommes préhistoriques, ont trouvé refuge dans une vallée étroite aux falaises majestueuses, traversée par la Düssel.
40 000 ans plus tard, cette rivière coule toujours
Un idéal, qui a inspiré les peintres et les poètes.
Aujourd'hui, ce serait une réserve naturelle.
Mais l'industrialisation est passée par là et la chaux de la vallée de Neander  est devenue une matière première très prisée pour la sidérurgie de la Ruhr.
Des milliers de personnes travaillent dans les carrières.
C'est la fin de la vallée de Neander .
Personne ne se doute alors, de ce que la découverte des ossements peut signifier.
Il s'agit bien sûr du fossile le plus connu au monde.
C'est d'ailleurs ce fossile qui, il y a 150 ans, nous a fait prendre conscience que d'autres espèces humaines, pas tout à fait comme nous, avaient existé.
À cette époque, personne ne croyait à l'existence d'hommes préhistoriques.
Seul Johann Fuhlrott, un enseignant, comprend immédiatement que ces os proviennent d'un homme de l'âge de pierre.
Les Néandertaliens ont-ils vraiment existé ?
Pour l'élite scientifique, cette question fait l'objet d'un débat acharné.
Le plus grand détracteur de cette théorie est Rudolf  Virchow, de Berlin, médecin le plus renommé de son époque et fondateur de la pathologie.
Il examine les os de très près et tire une conclusion, qui sera lourde de conséquences.
Ils viendraient d'un Homme moderne déformé par la maladie.
Les os d'un homme malade ?
Les mots de Virchow ont ancré le cliché du Néandertalien stupide, jusqu'à aujourd'hui.
Il est profondément ancré.
Sa posture voûtée, son regard terne, sa massue à la main.
C'est une image déformée.
40 000 ans plus tard, il est calomnié.
L'homme de Néandertal est un sauvage poilu.
Plus singe qu'humain, brutal, et stupide.
Un benêt de l'âge de pierre, inférieur à nous, en tout point.
En 1899, une découverte incroyable en Croatie fausse encore plus ce tableau.
Johannes Krause explore les grottes de Krapina.
C'est là qu'on a trouvé le plus d'os néandertaliens.
Dans l'état actuel de nos connaissances, on estime que le site de Krapina comptait entre 75, et 80 individus.
D'après un fragment dentaire.
Si vous étudiez le postcrânien, l'analyse sera peut-être un peu différente.
Les fouilles à Krapina font naître un soupçon macabre.
Ces Néandertaliens ne mangeaient-ils vraiment que de la viande animale ?
Des traces sur les os suggèrent quelque chose de terrible.
Certains évoquent le cannibalisme, car cela leur semble cohérent.
C'était un lieu où l'on pratiquait le cannibalisme.
Quelle est la raison de ce comportement cannibale ?
Nous n'en savons rien.
C'est peut-être la famine, ou un rituel.
Krapina est en effet un cas assez atypique.
Vous avez aussi des incisions sur les os.
Il semble donc qu'ils aient été dépecés, en quelque sorte.
Oui, plus ou moins dépecés.
Ils ne respectaient pas les morts.
Certains os sont brûlés.
Là encore, dans le cas du site de Krapina,  cette histoire de cannibalisme était bien connue.
À cause de cette fragmentation.
Beaucoup d'os sont fendus, cassés et fragmentés.
Dans son bureau du Musée croate d'histoire naturelle, à Zagreb, Radovčić montre à son collègue allemand, les preuves soigneusement conservées.
L'une des plus grandes collections de Néandertaliens au monde, des centaines d'ossements.
Certains ont été tellement abîmés qu'il ne peut y avoir qu'une seule explication,  d'après le chercheur.
Cette boîte contient beaucoup d'os, des os fendus, des os longitudinaux.
Prenez cet os, par exemple, certains voient là la preuve qu'on l'a fendu, afin d'en extraire la moelle.
C'est la preuve d'un comportement cannibale à Krapina.
Le long de ces os, ici et là, vous trouverez plusieurs incisions.
Comme pour enlever du tissu mou.
Il y a beaucoup d'os comme ça, de longs os.
Les Néandertaliens de Krapina étaient-ils donc des brutes cannibales ?
D'autres chercheurs, en doutent.
Ils ont découvert des marques mystérieuses sur l'un des crânes.
Une rangée de rayures à intervalles réguliers.
Il ne peut s'agir d'une coïncidence.
On voit beaucoup, beaucoup de rayures ici.
Elles sont très serrées, et elles sont très denses.
Comme si on voulait marquer,  ce spécimen, ou ,cette personne qui vient de mourir.
C'est un comportement plutôt surprenant pour Néandertal.
Qu'est-ce qu'il signifie ?
Nous n'en savons rien, mais ça pourrait être un signe de comportement symbolique.
Ce doute a suffi.
Les supposés cannibales de Krapina ont sali le nom de Néandertal pour de bon.
Un tel monstre ne convenait pas comme modèle, comme ancêtre.
Ce devait être une erreur abjecte de l'évolution.
L'Allemagne nazie faisait régner la loi de la jungle.
Et l'on disait que l'Aryen d'acier, avait anéanti l'inférieur Néandertal.
Un livre scolaire de l'époque, évoque le Néandertal grossier, qui était inférieur à la race noble.
Dans l'Allemagne d'Hitler, il n'y avait pas de place, pour les Néandertaliens.
Les nazis traitaient Néandertal avec dédain.
Néandertal n'était pas conforme à l'idéal racial des nazis.
Nous pouvons nous réjouir que le spécimen d'origine ait été préservé.
C'est pour cette raison  que les nazis firent fermer le premier musée allemand de Néandertal.
Son successeur moderne, situé près du site de la découverte, attire beaucoup de monde, aujourd'hui.
Néandertal, et sa massue ridicule, deviennent superstars de l'âge de pierre.
Une carrière épatante.
L'image que nous avons de nos plus proches parents, a changé radicalement depuis leur découverte.
Les chercheurs du monde entier s'intéressent à eux et à leur mode de vie.
Mais surtout, qu'avons-nous en commun ?
Les Néandertaliens se déplaçaient rapidement et complètement debout.
Ils avaient sûrement des yeux vifs et intelligents, ce qui explique leur survie.
Ils faisaient du feu, des habits, et savaient parler.
C'étaient des chasseurs très intelligents de l'ère glaciaire, qui vivaient comme le font les Inuits de nos jours, dans l'Arctique.
Il faut les voir ainsi.
Et vous serez sur la bonne voie.
On sait aujourd'hui que Néandertal était un être social,  comme nous.
C'était un véritable humain, un reflet de nous.
C'était surtout un habile chasseur,  dont le talent mûrit au fil des générations.
C'était le seul moyen de survivre dans cet environnement hostile.
L'initiation à la chasse, était une leçon très importante, dans la vie d'un Néandertalien.
Ils étaient plus rapides, plus musclés et plus forts que les Hommes modernes.
Aux Jeux olympiques, les Néandertaliens gagneraient presque toutes les médailles d'or.
Cette fascination pour l'Homme de Néandertal touche le monde entier.
L'Américain Eric Trinkaus, défend cette thèse depuis des années.
Nous nous sommes croisés et reproduits avec Néandertal.
J'ai toujours pensé aux processus de l'évolution de l'Homme de Néandertal et de l'Homme moderne, et à leurs interactions lorsqu'ils se sont croisés, quant aux populations, quant à la dynamique complexe des populations et des flux de gènes.
L'échange de partenaires, et la reproduction entre les populations, est un phénomène naturel.
Et j'ai toujours vu le monde ainsi.
Eric Trinkaus est l'un des plus grands spécialistes de Néandertal au monde.
Lors de ses fouilles dans le monde entier, il a découvert des squelettes, qui pourraient être issus d'une race mixte, de Néandertal,  et de nous.
Mais il lui manquait des preuves.
Le génie génétique n'était pas encore développé.
Et c'est ce qui fascine chez l'Homme de Néandertal.
Il est très proche de nous.
Il est presque nous, mais pas tout à fait.
Ils sont un reflet de nous, et en même temps, ce sont d'autres êtres humains.
Les Néandertaliens maîtrisaient des techniques raffinées.
Ils obtenaient des couleurs à partir de diverses pierres et fabriquaient des lances, qui n'avaient rien à envier aux instruments modernes.
Pour faire du feu, ils extrayaient l'amadou d'un champignon, qui pousse sur les arbres.
Ils étaient surtout d'habiles artisans de la pierre.
Ces maîtres ouvriers fabriquaient des racloirs et des pointes de lance acérées.
Ils méritent aussi notre respect.
Ils ont connu une époque très dure, dans un milieu très dangereux, avec une technologie, et un développement culturel global, très inférieurs aux nôtres.
Ils ont survécu dans ces conditions pendant des centaines de millénaires.
Et on rabaisse souvent les Néandertaliens, on les considère comme primitifs et stupides.
Je suis prêt à parier que si l'un d'entre nous, moi inclus, devait soudain retourner dans la société de Néandertal et qu'il devait vivre par ses propres moyens,  il tiendrait quelques mois, au mieux.
À Leipzig, les chercheurs de l'Institut Max Planck, analysent l'alimentation des Néandertaliens.
Dans le laboratoire isotope, d'infimes particules d'os de Néandertal sont examinées.
Résultat : l'alimentation des hommes préhistoriques était complètement différente, du nôtre.
Car il y a une chose dont ils avaient besoin plus que tout.
La viande,  beaucoup de viande.
On voit Néandertal comme une sorte de super prédateur.
Imaginons donc un groupe de lions,  vivant dans un territoire.
Et ces lions ont besoin de beaucoup de proies, ils doivent tuer,  ils doivent chasser des animaux pour survivre.
Et s'ils ne tuent pas assez d'animaux,  ils meurent.
Ce besoin de viande,  les anime.
Ils sont toujours en chasse.
Ils parcourent de longues distances pour tuer leur lot de proies.
Ils se contentent parfois de cerfs,  ou de rennes inoffensifs.
Mais Néandertal ne craint pas du tout le corps-a-corps avec des bêtes plus dangereuses, comme l'ours,  ou le mammouth.
Ils chassent en groupe,  et savent venir à bout d'un animal.
Et  le tuer.
Cela devait être,  très spectaculaire.
Imaginons un groupe de Néandertaliens traquant,  un jeune rhinocéros.
C'est quelque chose qui est vraiment difficile à concevoir car nous savons qu'ils n'avaient pas beaucoup d'armes,  pour tuer à distance.
Nous savons qu'ils avaient des lances en bois, des choses comme ça.
Mais,  la plupart de ces armes étaient probablement maniées à très courte distance.
Les proies devaient souvent être traînées sur des kilomètres jusqu'au camp.
Les Néandertaliens étaient donc beaucoup plus musclés que nous.
L'animal était dépecé,  devant la grotte.
Lorsqu'on dépend de la viande  au détriment d'autres sources d'alimentation, on est vulnérable.
Les proies peuvent se raréfier,  et, le climat peut changer radicalement.
Serait-ce une raison de leur disparition ?
L'extinction est une étape comme une autre de l'histoire évolutionnaire.
Un jour, nous disparaîtrons aussi.
Il est donc intéressant de comprendre comment Néandertal a survécu si longtemps.
Et pourquoi il a disparu.
À l'aide des méthodes les plus modernes, des anthropologues de l'Institut Max Planck de Laïpsich, tentent de percer ce mystère.
La mandibule d'un enfant de huit ans à peine, a été trouvée dans une grotte en Belgique.
C'est une découverte très précieuse, car les fossiles de jeunes Néandertaliens, sont rares.
Cette mâchoire est la clé d'un portail temporel,  vers les chasseurs de l'âge de pierre.
L'œil nu ne suffit pas.
Pour tirer plus d'informations de ce fossile, on le scanne en trois dimensions.
On révèle ainsi sa structure interne.
Les données obtenues, ont permis de créer une chose inédite dans l'histoire de la science : un Néandertalien virtuel.
Dans la salle de réalité virtuelle de Leipzig, le chercheur français Jean-Jacques Hublin observe la renaissance numérique de Néandertal.
Il a inventé cette technologie qui relie, depuis 1992, la préhistoire à la haute technologie.
Il a ainsi découvert une différence surprenante entre les humains, et Néandertal.
C'est un spécimen très intéressant et très important.
Donc il est très important d'examiner ce genre de fossile.
Nous avons ici la mandibule d'un enfant néandertalien.
Nous essayons d'évaluer la vitesse de développement de ces individus.
Nous avons ici une mandibule avec une deuxième molaire, qui a déjà poussé,  et une troisième molaire,  qui se développe à l'intérieur de la mandibule.
Selon les normes modernes, cet individu devrait avoir environ 12 ans.
Mais si l'on examine un peu la microstructure interne des dents, ces lignes qui se trouvent dans l'émail sont un peu comme les anneaux du bois, dans un tronc d'arbre.
Elles permettent de situer leur développement dans le temps.
Nous découvrons qu'en fait, cet individu n'avait que huit ans,  lorsqu'il est mort.
Cela signifie que les Néandertaliens, ou du moins leurs dents, se développaient plus vite que nous.
Les Néandertaliens avaient donc une enfance plus courte.
Ils avaient beaucoup moins de temps que nos enfants, pour apprendre à survivre et à chasser.
Cependant, ils pouvaient se débrouiller, beaucoup plus tôt.
Il existe bien sûr d'autres différences entre les humains et l'Homme de Néandertal.
Lorsqu'on regarde leur squelette pour la première fois, il est évident que ces deux espèces d'humains sont très différentes.
Jean-Jacques Hublin, compare deux squelettes.
Reconnaîtrait-on un Néandertalien, du premier coup ?
Si vous croisiez un Néandertalien dans la rue, ce qui vous semblerait le plus bizarre, serait son visage, et sa tête.
Ils avaient une grosse tête, et un grand cerveau, comme le nôtre.
Mais leur visage est très saillant,  par rapport à la boîte crânienne.
Ils avaient un front très fuyant,  ce qui constitue une différence majeure entre l'Homme moderne et Néandertal.
Leurs fortes arcades sourcilières surmontaient des orbites large, très larges.
Et tout leur visage est saillant,  le menton,  est absent.
Bien sûr, la vraie question est : "Qu'est-ce qui nous différencie, là-dedans ?"
Bien que Néandertal ait un grand cerveau comme les Hommes modernes,  nous savons qu'il s'est développé différemment,  en termes de vitesse.
Mais aussi en termes de forme et d'organisation interne.
Et nous aimerions vraiment savoir,  en quoi cela affecte le fonctionnement du cerveau.
Les Néandertaliens avaient leurs habitudes.
Ils se sont bien adaptés à leur environnement, et ont gardé le même mode de vie pendant des milliers d'années.
Contrairement à l'Homme moderne, qui innove,  et évolue.
On suppose que Néandertal vivait en groupes d'environ 20 personnes.
La population totale n'excédait pas les 20 000 personnes.
Les derniers Néandertaliens vivaient dans une Europe, très différente de celle d'aujourd'hui.
Durant le dernier âge glaciaire, il y a 39 000 ans, le Sud était couvert d'une forêt dense.
En Europe centrale, c'étaient surtout des conifères.
Au Nord, la toundra.
La Scandinavie était un semi-désert hostile, couronné d'une calotte glaciaire.
Les Néandertaliens, peu nombreux, ont peuplé une vaste région, de l'Espagne, à la Sibérie occidentale.
Ils laissèrent des traces partout.
Chaque point indique un site où des découvertes ont été faites.
Le plus connu d'entre eux se trouve à Neanderthal, en Allemagne.
C'est là qu'on a découvert le tout premier Néandertalien.
Ralf Schmitz, est déterminé à trouver le reste.
Et fouille ce site légendaire, 150 ans plus tard.
La plus grande aventure de sa carrière.
Ça devient vraiment intéressant quand on entre dans cette zone.
La vraie zone d'excavation se trouve à quelques mètres sous la surface.
Elle est protégée par plusieurs couches.
Vingt mètres plus haut, se trouve la grotte où les ossements de Néandertal ont été trouvés.
La paroi rocheuse et la grotte, ont été détruites pour en extraire la chaux.
Les sédiments de la grotte ont dû finir au fond de la vallée, au 19e siècle.
Pour trouver d'autres ossements néandertaliens, il faut d'abord savoir si la terre des grottes a été transportée hors de la vallée en 1856,  ou non.
Une décharge couvre la zone qu'ils veulent fouiller.
Cependant, malgré les obstacles, les travaux à Neandertal commencent  en automne 1997.
Les chercheurs ont-ils vraiment choisi le bon endroit ?
Les semaines passent, sans trouvaille significative.
Les sacs de terre sont dégagés un à un,  et tamisés à la main.
La moindre particule est examinée.
C'est un travail laborieux.
Peu avant la fin des fouilles, une lueur d'espoir apparaît.
Un morceau d'os.
Provient-il d'un être humain ?
Nous l'avons nettoyé et il est apparu que ce n'était pas un simple morceau d'os, mais un os malaire humain.
En le comparant à un crâne en plastique d'Homme moderne,  nous avons constaté que l'os trouvé, était plus grand.
Nous avons tout de suite compris que c'était un os malaire de Néandertal.
Os par os, le squelette est reconstitué.
Cinquante autres fragments sont retrouvés.
L'os malaire nous donne une idée de ce à quoi pouvait ressembler le premier Européen.
C'est un peu comme un puzzle.
Les plus importants sont ceux qui correspondent au squelette original.
Le tout premier que nous essayons, est un petit fragment du fémur gauche.
Si vous regardez ce fémur près de la rotule,  vous pouvez voir qu'il manque de petits morceaux.
C'est arrivé lorsque les ouvriers de la carrière ont frappé les os dans la terre, avec leurs bêches.
Lorsque les os se sont assemblés, c'était un grand moment dans l'histoire de l'archéologie.
J'étais fou d'excitation, c'était si important que j'ai failli m'évanouir.
Cela prouverait enfin que nous avons redécouvert le site d'origine de Néandertal.
La clé de l'énigme Néandertal se trouve à Laïpsiche.
Une équipe internationale de chercheurs, menée par Svante Pääbo, a mis au point des techniques révolutionnaires pour séquencer l'ADN ancien.
Nous avons très longtemps travaillé sur les animaux, les ours des cavernes, et les mammouths.
Ensuite, quand nous avons compris que ça marchait, nous avons tenté de mettre la main sur les os de Néandertal.
Nous avons finalement obtenu le soutien de Ralf.
Ralf Schmitz, gardien du Néandertalien original, a accepté de leur confier un humérus.
Des échantillons sont prélevés.
De la farine est extraite de l'os, puis examinée.
Contiendra-t-elle assez de matériel génétique, pour cracker le code génétique de Néandertal ?
Après 40 000 ans, ce serait un coup de chance.
Bien sûr, il est important que l'ADN ait été préservé dans cet os.
Seuls 10 % des os examinés contiennent vraiment de l'ADN.
Les chances sont bonnes.
Car l'humérus de Néandertal est non seulement bien conservé,  mais aussi étonnamment bien développée.
Quelle en est la raison ?
Dans sa jeunesse, cet homme a subi une fracture du coude.
Pour le restant de sa vie, il avait un usage très limité de son bras gauche.
Il était handicapé, en quelque sorte.
C'est clairement visible, car le bras gauche est nettement plus mince que le bras droit.
Si je les mets côte à côte, vous pouvez les comparer.
En tant qu'handicapé, il a été soigné par son groupe pendant 20 ans.
Ça en dit plus sur Néandertal que le feraient 10 millions d'outils en pierre.
Ils n'étaient pas seulement de braves chasseurs,  mais aussi des humains solidaires.
Les blessures et les fractures  faisaient partie du quotidien.
Ils prenaient soin des membres de la tribu.
Car leur survie dépendait de chacun de ces membres.
Ils pouvaient soigner des blessures graves.
Autrement dit, Néandertal devait avoir des notions médicales de base.
La quête quotidienne de nourriture était dangereuse.
Certains ont comparé ce type de blessures, et de fractures, avec celles que peuvent recevoir les cavaliers de rodéo.
C'est un peu la même chose, en fait.
Il semble donc qu'ils affrontent physiquement ces animaux.
Il y a aussi une mortalité assez haute, chez les adultes.
C'est donc probablement un des facteurs clés de la démographie néandertalienne :  le risque élevé de mourir jeune.
Les Néandertaliens avaient peu de chances d'atteindre l'âge de 40 ans.
Leur dernière demeure, était toujours une grotte.
La tribu veillait à ce que le corps soit protégé des charognards.
Ils couchaient les morts sur le dos, ou recroquevillés sur le côté,  dans une position proche du sommeil.
On ne sait pas s'ils croyaient en des dieux ou en une vie après la mort.
On trouve des signes de rituels funéraires et de cultes mortuaires.
Mais il est impossible d'être plus précis, après 10 000 ans.
Une chose est claire, cependant.
Ils étaient humains,  et ils pleuraient leurs morts.
La question est maintenant : "Dans quelle mesure sont-ils différents,  et de quelle nature sont ces différences ?"
Et pour qu'une espèce en remplace une autre,  il ne doit pas nécessairement y avoir une très grande différence entre ces deux espèces.
En décodant le génome de Néandertal, l'équipe de Laïpsiche espère répondre à de nombreuses questions.
Pourquoi ont-ils disparu,  et pourquoi l'Homme moderne a-t-il survécu ?
L'extraction de la séquence génétique à partir d'un échantillon d'os du Néandertalien original, a réussi.
C'est la première fois avec un humain disparu.
A mon avis,  notre intérêt pour le génome néandertalien ne concerne pas Néandertal lui-même,  mais notre propre histoire,  celle de l'Homme moderne.
Car l'Homme de Néandertal est notre plus proche parent.
Puis, les obstacles surgissent.
Le Néandertalien original ne fournit pas assez de matière pour continuer, et certains os sont contaminés.
Lorsqu'on travaille avec l'ADN néandertalien, le plus gros problème est la contamination humaine.
Humain et Néandertal sont très proches.
Cela signifie que si je contamine l'ADN de l'extrait d'os avec de l'ADN humain,  je ne peux plus faire la différence entre les deux.
Les os passent par beaucoup de mains,  et chacune y laisse des traces.
Pour les généticiens, ce problème semble d'abord insoluble.
On commence à chercher des osnon contaminés dans toute l'Europe.
Nous avons examiné beaucoup d'os pour n'en trouver que cinq qui avaient assez d'ADN, et une contamination assez basse, pour être utiles au projet.
C'est en Croatie, que les chasseurs de gènes trouvent leur bonheur.
La piste mène à Zagreb, à la très ancienne Académie des sciences et des arts.
Johannes Krause est à l'endroit même où se trouve la clé qui déchiffrera le code de Néandertal.
En sûreté, dans une armoire vitrée.
Ce précieux fossile est resté plusieurs décennies dans un tiroir poussiéreux .
Jusqu'à ce que l'équipe de Leipzig, arrive sur place.
Nous avons mené une analyse génétique des os et trouvé de l'ADN de Néandertal dans beaucoup d'entre eux.
C'est-à-dire que nous avons tiré de l'ADN de tous les os que vous voyez là.
L'ADN de Néandertal a donc été préservé pendant des millénaires.
Nous avons observé ces os pour voir s'ils étaient utiles au projet.
Ils le sont.
L'un des os contient beaucoup d'informations.
Les chercheurs l'appellent "os d'or".
C'était le plus exploitable.
Contrairement aux autres os, il n'est que très légèrement contaminé par l'ADN humain.
Dans cette boîte, se trouvent les os  qui nous ont donné la clé du génome de Néandertal.
En route vers le site où les os ont été découverts.
Il se trouve dans une forêt dense, à 30 kilomètres au nord de Zagreb.
Accompagné de deux collègues croates, Johannes Krause visite la grotte de Vindija, l'un des sites néandertaliens les plus importants en Europe.
Des générations de Néandertaliens ont vécu dans cette grotte,  jusqu'à ce qu'ils disparaissent.
C'est un site, où l'on trouve quelques-uns des plus jeunes Néandertaliens jamais découverts.
Sûrement les plus jeunes Néandertaliens de cette partie de l'Europe.
Ils vivaient à une époque très intéressante,  qu'on appelle souvent le "changement bioculturel", du Paléolithique moyen au Paléolithique supérieur.
Il y a environ 40 à 30 000 ans.
Et c'est une époque où des groupes de personnes à l'anatomie moderne, comme nous, vivent dans certaines parties de l'Europe.
Cette grotte était très fréquentée par les hommes préhistoriques.
Treize couches archéologiques sont fouillées,  la plupart d'entre elles contiennent des restes de Néandertaliens.
Je trouve merveilleux de penser que des Néandertaliens ont vécu là, dans cette grotte.
Nous nous tenons à l'endroit même où une autre espèce d'humain a vécu, et trouvé refuge, il y a 30 000 ans.
C'est une sensation incroyable de savoir que Néandertal a certainement vécu là et a laissé ses os.
Cependant, il ont pu être amenés là.
Ils ont pu être apportés là par des hyènes.
Les chercheurs ont atteint les tréfonds de la grotte.
Cela aurait pu arriver ici.
Les Néandertaliens et les Hommes modernes,  se sont rencontrés.
Se sont-ils mélangés ?
Certains pensent que la réponse se lit dans les os.
Certains, pensent que Néandertal s'est métissé avec certains groupes d'humains à l'anatomie moderne, dès lors qu'il est arrivé en Europe.
Mais il a également pu se métisser bien avant cela, avec différents autres groupes d'êtres humains.
Donc on se demande si l'on peut le voir dans la gracilité ou dans certains traits morphologiques de Vindija.
C'est une question que l'on se pose souvent,  lorsqu'on étudie ces os fossiles.
Ces os font l'objet de nombreuses spéculations.
La première rencontre entre l'Homme de Néandertal et l'Homme moderne, aurait pu se dérouler aux alentours de Vindija.
Mais les experts en génétique affirment que cela n'aurait pas pu se produire en Croatie.
Si les Néandertaliens et les Hommes modernes s'étaient réellement mélangés en Europe, on trouverait plus d'ADN chez les Européens d'aujourd'hui, que chez les Asiatiques d'aujourd'hui.
Et ce n'est pas le cas.
On trouve le même ADN néandertalien en Europe qu'en Asie et qu'en Asie du Sud-Est.
À Leipzig, les os de Vindija font progresser le séquençage du code génétique néandertalien.
Grâce à eux, les chercheurs espèrent même pouvoir lire l'intégralité du génome.
Pour pouvoir comprendre ce message qui remonte à l'âge de pierre, il ne suffira pas d'examiner les gènes de l'homme préhistorique.
Pour en savoir plus, par exemple sur leur capacité à parler, une comparaison doit être faite.
Entre notre plus proche parent disparu, Néandertal,  et notre plus proche parent vivant.
Le chimpanzé.
Les grands singes partagent 99 % de leurs gènes avec nous.
Six millions d'années d'évolution nous séparent.
Durant six millions d'années, les chimpanzés et les humains ont accumulé environ 20 millions de mutations génétiques.
Au total, la différence est d'environ 1 %,  donc nous sommes en effet très proches les uns des autres.
Mais les singes ne parlent pas.
Le généticien Wolfgang Enard, effectue des recherches sur les chimpanzés, au zoo de Laïpsiche.
Lorsqu'un gène du langage a été découvert en Angleterre, en 2001,  Enard a constaté que ce gène n'existait pas chez les singes.
Serait-ce vraiment l'un des gènes du langage, qui a fait une différence si cruciale entre nous,  et notre plus proche parent dans le monde animal ?
C'est la difficulté que l'on rencontre, lorsqu'on met le doigt sur un gène.
Nous pensons qu'il s'est passé une chose très importante dans l'évolution de l'Homme, ce qu'on ne peut évidemment pas vérifier directement.
On ne peut pas modifier ce gène directement chez l'homme ou le chimpanzé.
Nous devons donc avoir une sorte d'accès expérimental.
Par exemple, sur l'organisme modèle le plus important qu'on a, à savoir la souris.
La souris nous permet de déterminer ce qui différencie les diverses variations du gène.
Et en fin de compte, la souris nous ressemble beaucoup.
Wolfgang Enard veut savoir ce qui se passe lorsqu'on implante un gène du langage dans une souris.
Il est vrai que la souris ne se met pas à parler, mais elle change, et très distinctement.
Nous allons plus loin et constatons que ce changement affecte le cerveau de la souris d'une certaine manière,  de sorte que nous pensons pouvoir l'associer à certaines caractéristiques linguistiques.
Et nous l'étudions de plus près afin de mieux le définir.
Mais nous avons fait le premier pas.
Il agit d'une certaine manière, sur les neurones et les zones du cerveau responsables du langage humain.
La capacité de parler est une qualité propre à l'être humain.
Le modèle de la souris prouve que le gène du langage récemment découvert doit jouer un rôle important dans la parole.
Tandis que Wolfgang Enard étudie les couinements du rongeur, l'équipe de Svante Pääbo trouve exactement le même gène, chez l'Homme de Néandertal.
En effet, la souris couine un peu différemment et des changements surviennent dans son cerveau.
Ils sont certainement importants, et nous les partageons avec Néandertal.
La première partie du code de Néandertal a été décryptée.
C'est une technologie de pointe qui a rendu possible la percée finale.
Cette technologie a permis de déterminer 100 millions de séquences d'ADN en une seule fois.
C'est un million de fois plus que ce que pouvais faire cette ancienne machine.
Nous avons ainsi pu produire autant de données que nécessaire pour décoder le génome de Néandertal.
Enfin, après 13 ans d'études scientifiques, l'objectif est atteint.
Le génome de Néandertal est décodé.
Le résultat, est sensationnel.
Ils se sont un peu mélangés, et il y a un peu de Néandertal en nous.
Mais combien ?
Pour trouver la réponse, les chercheurs étudient aussi l'Homme moderne.
Ils comparent le gène Néandertal avec un génotype d'hommes et de femmes, tous issus de cinq régions différentes du monde.
Le résultat est à nouveau surprenant.
La répartition de l'héritage néandertalien, varie  dans le monde entier.
Le plus étonnant avec ces résultats, c'est qu'on trouve cette petite contribution chez les Européens et les Asiatiques, mais pas chez les Africains.
Il semble que les Européens et les Asiatiques aient quelque chose en commun, une petite partie du génome néandertalien.
C'est une révolution.
Jusqu'alors, nous pensions être totalement différents des Néandertaliens.
Le grand mystère.
Comment les Néandertaliens ont-ils pu contribuer à des régions du monde qui n'ont jamais été habitées par Néandertal ?
La théorie la plus probable est que cela s'est produit très tôt.
Ce mélange avec Néandertal, les ancêtres néandertaliens de Croatie que nous avons étudiés.
Ça a probablement eu lieu au Moyen-Orient.
Tout commence en Afrique, il y a 500 000 ans.
Les premiers hominidés se séparent en plusieurs lignées.
Les ancêtres de l'Homme à l'anatomie moderne, et les ancêtres de l'Homme de Néandertal.
Les premiers Hommes de Néandertal migrent, s'installent à l'est, et se répandent dans toute l'Europe.
Environ 100 000 à 50 000 ans avant notre ère, l'Homme moderne migre aussi d'Afrique, et se reproduit avec l'Homme de Néandertal.
Dans leur marche triomphale à travers le monde, ils emportent une toute petite part d'ADN néandertalien, dans leur bagage génétique.
Ils le répandent dans des régions jamais habitées par l'Homme de Néandertal.
En résumé, les Néandertaliens sont bien nos ancêtres.
Nous sommes une famille.
Néandertal, c'est nous, et je trouve merveilleux qu'il reste quelque chose de ces fascinants chasseurs de l'ère glaciaire.
28 000 ans avant notre ère, l'Homme de Néandertal disparait.
Les humains qui portent leurs gènes sont retournés en Afrique.
Ce n'est qu'au sud du Sahara qu'on ne trouve plus d'ADN néandertalien.
J'aime à penser que le grand public serait heureux de savoir que nous avons un peu de l'Homme de Néandertal en nous.
C'étaient des durs, c'étaient des humains durables.
Ils vivaient dans des conditions très rudes.
Ils ont survécu des centaines de millénaires.
Je serais très fier de savoir que j'ai des Néandertaliens parmi mes ancêtres.
Nous avons beaucoup en commun avec Néandertal.
Par exemple, des fouilles menées dans toute l'Europe ont révélé que, comme nous, les hommes préhistoriques se maquillaient,  avec des couleurs à base d'argile.
Et pourtant, ils étaient différents.
En quoi sommes-nous différents ?
Qu'est-ce qui nous rend si uniques ?
Par exemple, pourquoi les Néandertaliens ne produisaient-ils pas d'art ?
Je ne peux toujours pas expliquer pourquoi Néandertal nous égale en tout, hormis le fait qu'il ne produisait pas d'art.
L'Homme moderne était le premier à introduire l'art en Europe, il y a 40 000 ans.
Cette différence peut-elle être identifiée génétiquement ?
Dans une salle blanche, Johannes Krause rend une séquence de gènes de Néandertal visible à l'œil humain.
En déchiffrant le code de Néandertal, les chercheurs espèrent aujourd'hui pouvoir découvrir les tout derniers secrets de l'humanité.
On peut aller au-delà des flux de gènes,  et de la reproduction des uns et des autres durant le Pléistocène.
Nous pouvons nous interroger, sur la biologie, sur les comportements, sur l'adaptation.
Cela nous permettra peut-être de savoir ce qui a fait que ce modèle, dans la biologie humaine moderne, ce modèle biologique de l'Homme moderne, s'est avéré le plus efficace.
L'Homme moderne ne réussit pas simplement parce qu'il sait mieux communiquer.
Pendant des millénaires, Néandertal n'a presque pas changé.
Mais nous sommes flexibles.
Nous pouvons deviner ce que pense quelqu'un.
Nous pouvons penser en symboles.
Mais nous sommes aussi une espèce agressive, et nous ne laissons pas de place aux autres espèces, ni aux autres humains.
Le code de Néandertal nous procure la clé des questions les plus importantes, en ce qui nous concerne.
Comparer et apprendre pourrait même servir à comprendre, et affronter les défis de l'avenir de l'humanité.
Le vrai mystère est la raison pour laquelle une espèce, la nôtre, a tant perduré.
Pourquoi est-elle si  envahissante ?
Comment a-t-elle pu recouvrir toute la planète,  et être si prospère,  si féconde.
Les Néandertaliens étaient très talentueux à bien des égards.
Ils vécurent des millénaires,  dans des conditions très rudes,  malgré les changements climatiques  et les périodes glaciaires.
Tenant tête à la nature,  jusqu'à ce qu'un évènement inattendu les prenne de court.
Penser qu'une cause naturelle aurait conduit à l'extinction de l'Homme de Néandertal,  au moment même où l'Homme moderne s'installait en Europe,  après 20 ou 30 centaines de milliers d'années, vous savez, de hauts et de bas dans la population...
Ce serait une coïncidence incroyable,  que cela se produise au moment de l'arrivée de l'Homme moderne.
L'arrivée de l'Homme moderne sur la terre de l'Homme de Néandertal, il y a 40 000 ans,  a marqué le début de la fin .
Ils s'emparent des terrains de chasse de Néandertal.
Ils se reproduisent beaucoup plus vite.
Le nombre d'Hommes préhistoriques diminue.
Ils sont repoussés aux frontières de leur terre d'origine.
Leur culture, est perdue à jamais.
Leur savoir-faire,  leur talent de chasseur.
Leur solidarité de tribue,  est ruinée.
Mais  aujourd'hui,  nous en savons plus que jamais,  sur nos frères disparus.
Ce tableau, ce puzzle de Néandertal gagne de plus en plus en couleurs.
Ils continueront à nous fournir de la matière à étudier pendant au moins 50, voire 100 ans.
L'Homme de Néandertal a disparu,  il y a près de 30 000 ans.
Nous seuls,  Hommes modernes,  dominons aujourd'hui la planète.
Mais une petite part de Néandertal a survécu.
En chacun de nous,  jusqu'à aujourd'hui.